bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous
sur lcp public sénat c'est l'heure de
parlement hebdo nous sommes 60 pour 45
minutes d'émission avec vous qu'elles
avaient mangé au caviar
bonjour alors le temps fort c'est bien
sûr les élections départementales la
droite est arrivé en tête du premier
tour l'union ump udi et parfois modem a
payé le fn a pris la deuxième position
le parti socialiste lui accuse le coup
de la défaite mais dans ses rangs de
nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour appeler
au rassemblement de toute la gauche
et pan dans cet entre-deux-tours le
match manuel valls nicolas sarkozy est
reparti le premier ministre accuse le
président de l'ump d'avoir commis une
faute politique et morale refusant de
faire barrage au front national par la
fameuse stratégie du ni-ni et le front
national sera présent dans près d'un
canton sur deux le parti de marine le
pen espère conquérir au moins un
département le vaucluse le nord où il y
encore l'aisne où nous irons où
justement prendre le tout des électeurs
reportage à voir tout à l'heure et on va
commenter toute cette actualité riche
évidemment les tours des élections
départementales avec vous pour l'heure
au bonjour bonjour vous êtes secrétaire
nationale du parti communiste français
sénateur de paris vous est aussi
président du parti de la gauche
européenne alors vous connaissez la
formule on a interrogé quelques
parlementaires pour dresser un peu votre
portrait
évidemment vous réagirez juste après 7,1
millions et moi je reconnais que les
militants ils doivent faut apporter
aussi une reconnaissance de la part de
l'ensemble des acteurs de la vie
politique voyez la politique ça dépasse
aussi une guerre de tranchées il ya des
hommes et des femmes qui ont des vies
différent des avis différents des
comportements différents toujours se
poser la question je pense qu'il se la
pose de ce que la gauche peuvent faire
ensemble terre dans la réalité dans le
concret le congrès s'est les villes
c'est des départements et les régions
c'est aussi l'état mais moi je crois
reconnaître à pierre laurent cette forme
de sincérité de ne pas être simplement
dans du de l'idéologie c'est quelqu'un
que je connais relativement peu et que
j'inviterai donc ses plus hauts
responsables politiques que
j'appellerais une je m'adresserai
j'inviterai à ouvrir parfois un petit
peu les yeux sur l'évolution de la
société de ne pas trop s'arc bouter sur
sur certains sujets écoutez ça m'a l'air
d'être quelqu'un de très sérieux très
sérieux et de très honnête
mais d'un peu décalé malheureusement par
rapport aux réalités
on sent un discours qui est un petit peu
trop formaté qui celui du parti du parti
communiste c'est un discours qui ne
passent plus aujourd'hui auprès des
français donc je crois qu'il devrait
profondément se remettre en cause et
surtout remettre en cause son parti même
si par ailleurs je ne doute pas de sa
sincérité et de la qualité de l'homme
qu'il est bon ça mérite quand même une
petite réflexion avec vous faites oui
non juste que je suis toujours très
étonné quand on dit la sincérité
l'honnêteté voilà formidable mais la vie
réelle c'est autre chose
il ya des millions de gens qui sont très
sincère dans ce pays et qui disent qu'il
faut changer de politique et que le
système dans lequel on nous enferme
produits de plus en plus d'inégalités de
catastrophe donc la sincérité c'est pas
juste comme ça des bons sentiments c'est
aussi le réalisme d'une seule de se
rendre compte que cette société elle va
dans le mur c'est peut-être ce qu'ils
font ces remarques qui devrait se
remettre en cause parce qu'à force de
répéter les mêmes dogmes
le résultat c'est beaucoup de souffrance
dans la société français voulait ça
s'est arrêté en politique c'est
l'essentiel moi je pense que c'est
essentiel oui je pense qu'il faut
toujours tenir un discours de vérité il
faut voilà il faut avoir des valeurs on
politique l'éthique en politique pour
moi ça compte beaucoup
je ne crois pas aux petits calculs
mesquins où j'avais fait la une en or
des électeurs à faire des shows discours
de vérité churchill savoureux sens alors
là je n'ai pas la prétention de l'être
pour le moment au niveau de churchill
dans les politiques encourageant mais il
ya justement trop de
deux responsables politiques qui croient
qu'on peut dire une chose aux électeurs
et puis après faire exactement le
contraire et c'est ce que les gens ne
supportent plus et je les comprends
totalement à lyon passera lundi à
banaliser le premier tour de ces
élections départementales et pour rappel
on va commencer par les résultats
officiels du ministère de l'intérieur
l'ump udi arrive en tête avec 29 51 %
des voix suivi du front national 25,72
et 21 78 pour le parti socialiste alors
état des lieux forces en présence pour
ce deuxième tour dimanche prochain avec
flora sauvage
rien n'est joué dimanche prochain la
bataille s'annonce serrée
c'est la surprise du premier tour des
départementales il y a plus de
triangulaire que prévu au total le
second tour il y aura 3 128 triangulaire
et 1577 duels le front national sera
présent dans 298 triangulaires et une
quadrangulaire
il affrontera la gauche dans 284 canton
et la droite dans 532 canton si le fn a
choisi de se maintenir au second tour ce
n'est pas forcément le cas des autres
formations politiques
au ps la consigne a été donnée de se
désister pour contrer les candidats
frontistes dans le département de
l'aisne où le front national est arrivé
en tête dans tous les cantons
deux triangulaires vont avoir lieu à
l'ump la consigne nationale du ni-ni n'a
pas forcément été respectée par les
candidats locaux dans le gard où le fn
est arrivée largement en tête avec plus
de 35% des voix le sénateur maire de
nîmes jean paul fournier appelle à voter
en faveur du candidat de gauche lors des
sept duels qui vont opposer la gauche et
le fn
dimanche soir les résultats des
élections diront si les stratégies
adoptées par les états majors des partis
auront été payante
alors dimanche soir la gauche unie ça
c'est nouveau pour ce deuxième tour on
garderait combien département écoutez ça
je j'ai pas envie de faire de pronostic
juste une remarque parce que vous avez
donné les résultats mais vous n'avez pas
donné le résultat des candides de nos
candidats des candidats du
front gauche je comprends votre embarras
parce que le ministère de l'intérieur
nous a classé donc je crois au moins
quatre quatre catégories différentes
pour que ça devienne illisible
donc nous on a refait les additions et
les binômes de qui était soutenu par le
parti communiste par le front de gauche
et des fois d'autres formations puisque
nous avions des bills ont de commun avec
europe écologie les verts dans toute une
série de cantons ont fait 9 4% donc
c'est à peu près un point au dessus
d'eux des deux séries départementales à
celle de l'intérieur dans le ministère
de l'intérieur lui il nous aurait éclaté
alors il ya des candidats qui sont
classés particules front de gauche front
de gauche outre divers gauche de nous
expliquer cet émiettement à ce que c'est
le fait par exemple de cette imposition
d'avoir des binômes pour ces élections
mais parce que tout simplement le
ministère de l'intérieur pouvait très
bien compter les fonctions et les
binômes en fonction des étiquettes
politiques des candidats qu'il est
constitué et il a fait du tripatouillage
bon c'est pas c'est pas très digne d'une
manoeuvre politique
oui non mais c'est tout ça c'était pour
qu'on ne voie à l'arrivée qu'on ne
rendre lisible à l'arrivée que les
résultats de l'ump du front national et
du parti socialiste parce que derrière
ça on essaye d'installer un paysage qui
se réduirait à sabha le paysage
politique français ne se réduit pas à ça
et à gauche il ya beaucoup il ya des
forces qui cherchent une autre voie qui
présentait des candidats comme henry et
qui existent et qui redonne dont une
force et donc je tripartisme pour vous
il est imposé par les forces politiques
oui ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui bien sûr
il ya des yade et on voit bien qu'il ya
un scénario qu'on essaye de nous en
poser qui serait de réduire le choix
politique des prochaines échéances à où
l'ump où le front national où la
politique du gouvernement actuel
eh bien ça n'est pas ça la france en
titre c'est qu'ils vous pensez à qui
leur en parler du ministère de
l'intérieur
je crois que les trois formations aux
questions cherche
à jouer ce à jouer ce jeu là on sent que
c'est comme ça qu'on va réduire le
paysage politique à ceux à ce trio là
pour les prochaines échéances
et heureusement à gauche il se cherche
une voie nouvelle et je bien ce qu'elle
va s'imposer pour justement ces
élections dans ces élections il y avait
aussi les verts europe écologie mais le
scrutin met en évidence la faiblesse
politique de cette formation avec 2% des
voix au niveau national le parti est
divisé en réalité entre ceux qui veulent
retourner au gouvernement et les autres
qui veulent faire bande à part en
appelant car laurent à la création d'une
nouvelle force de gauche état des lieux
des positions avec rim benameur climat
tendu chez les verts la division entre
partisans d'un retour au gouvernement et
les autres s'affiche de plus en plus
d'un côté la ligne duflot l'ancien
ministre de l'écologie semble se
rapprocher de l'extrême gauche elle
écarte tout retour au gouvernement et ne
se gêne pas pour le critiquer la vérité
c'est qu'il ya une claque pour la gauche
lors de ses premiers tours des élections
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas se
mobiliser pour dimanche prochain
il faut quand même être lucide sur la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons donc le temps des bilans ce
sera après le deuxième tour
et si le cap du gouvernement change ceux
que je croise nécessaire pour le pays
parce que si la gauche va mal et que le
pays va pas très bien
de l'autre côté la ligne favorable un
retour aux fonctions ministérielles jean
vincent placé françois de rugy et même
emmanuelle cosse pressenti pour un
maroquin il souhaite un rapprochement
avec le ps c'est notre responsabilité
commune à tous les mouvements de gauche
en premier lieu au parti socialiste au
chef de l'état et au chef du
gouvernement est aussi aux écologistes
notre responsabilité de réfléchir
ensemble à comment nous pouvons aborder
les deux dernières années de mandat de
façon utile pour conduire un certain
nombre de réformes
un certain nombre de changements deux
orientations politiques des résultats
faibles aux élections départementales
le parti sort affaiblie désormais chaque
camp affine sa stratégie pour le
lendemain du second tour et surtout en
cas de remaniement ministériel
revoilà père laurent les verts semblent
avoir des positions différentes ce qui
forme un ensemble assez cacophonique
est ce que pour vous ils sont en partie
responsable de l'échec de la gauche non
c'est trop facile
et d'ailleurs même je suis pas là pour
défendre je suis pas le porte parole
d'europe écologie les verts mais vous
travaillerez sur les chiffres mais sur
les chiffres de la vo idiot mais non ils
ont l'oeil ils ont eu la même difficulté
que nous c'est que le ministère de
l'intérieur a éclaté les résultats là où
il y avait des binômes entre un parti
communiste ou un front de gauche europe
ecologie les verts en moyenne ces
binômes ont fait 13 % à peu près donc
c'est pas des résultats c'est pas des
résultats négligeables pas encore
suffisant mais pas négligeable et je
pense que nous posons de plus en plus
souvent des questions des questions
communes je sais qu'ils ont le débat sur
le retour au gouvernement mais le
problème du câble gouvernementale est un
pro c'est un problème qui se pose à nous
tous par exemple comment est-ce qu'on
peut prétendre faire de la transition
écologique réussi si on continue de
taper comme on est en train de le faire
dans les budgets d'investissements
publics des collectivités locales dont
quelques si nous dites que vous êtes
satisfait aujourd'hui de cet accord vous
avez passé avec les verts dans certains
départements mais c'est pas encore ça
non mais il faut que les forces qui
veulent une réorientation de la
politique gouvernementale monte en
puissance
elle commence à faire des choses
ensemble elles ont travaillé ensemble
dans cette élection avec europe ecologie
les verts avec nouvelle donne avec des
socialistes d ici ou là qui qui qui
maintenant disent clairement leur
désaccord avec la politique
gouvernementale mais il faut que tout ça
monte en puissance parce que et pour le
des lâches le deuxième tour non mais oui
paris que mais parle c'est pour ça mais
non mais c'est très simple c'est que
pour faire progresser ce combat aucune
de nos forces n'a intérêt à ce que la
droite et l'extrême droite prennent des
positions supplémentaires donc au
deuxième tour il faut empêcher la droite
et l'extrême droite de prendre des
positions supplémentaires parce que ça
ne fera pas avancer nos objectifs mais
ça les fera reculer mais le problème
posé pour la suite d'un changement de
cap gouvernemental
est toujours sur la table est plus que
jamais après les résultats du premier
tour il faut entendre tout le message
email
oui une image celle du déplacement de
manuel valls à fresnes dans le val de
marne département qui pourrait basculer
à droite ce dimanche
pas de meeting pour le premier ministre
mais une rencontre avec des militants et
des électeurs
une question très simple val d'un
département symbolique la de vos
passions sur le point d'être conquis par
la droite ce serait un échec pour vous
enfin il n'est pas sur le point d'être
contre il a conquis par la droite
il est sur le point d'être conservée à
gauche les résultats du premier tour
montre pas craint qu'une montre il ya
nous sommes nous sommes vigilants parce
qu'on voit bien qu'il faut un effort de
mobilisation électorale supplémentaire
mais les conditions sont réunies pour
que ce département dont le président est
mon ami christian famille qui est
sénateur sur une liste est bien pour que
ce département puisse conserver son
orientation et donc des politiques
sociales extrêmement utile à ce
département populaire et je pense que
nous allons nous allons y parvenir en
tout cas nous y travaillons vous pensez
de gagner encore regardé dimanche
prochain oui travail le garder nous
parce que c'est pas eu de la sphère
partisane mais gardez a continué à
majorité de gauche qui va mener des
politiques qui sont des politiques
sociales on pourrait détailler mais il
ya des choses formidables qui sont
drôles de parler d'union de la gauche
vous étiez présent un autre meeting
c'était cette fois en seine saint denis
on l'a suivi avec caroline mode on va
regarder ce reportage et plus on en
parle juste après le duel du second tour
s'annonce très serrée en seine saint
denis
dimanche prochain ce bastion historique
de la gauche pourrait bien passer à
droite à la faveur d'une vague bleue le
chef de file ump crois bien que la donne
a changé
notre objectif c'est de faire basculer
ce département les résultats du premier
tour
après ceux des municipales de l'an
dernier
nous sommes maintenant aux commandes de
la moitié des communes du département
ces résultats ont montré qu'il est tout
à fait possible que dimanche prochain
nous soyons majoritaire dans le
département
c'est à dire qu'il nous faut remporter
onze cantons sur les 21 le 93 détient le
triste record d'abstention 63% des
électeurs n'ont pas voté au premier tour
ce couple de pavillons sous bois ne
compte pas se rendre aux urnes dimanche
je vais pas voter quoi parce que je suis
pas intéressé parce que je trouve que
voilà ça change rien qui changea pas
dévolue à cette évolution est contraire
à la france bat on va grèce quoi quand
j'entends les différents partis qui
s'exprime
j'ai l'impression d'entendre la même
chose mais juste dit différemment
et si la gauche perdait son fief
historique pour cet habitant
ce serait une bonne nouvelle je ne dis
pas que la gauche ces jeux mauvais
travail même si je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec leur politique mais je
pense que si ça basculera droit je pense
que le 93 a besoin de changement alors
hier soir à bondy la gauche s'est
rassemblée pour un dernier meeting
socialistes écologistes communistes et
radicaux de gauche tous réunis pour
faire barrage à la droite une vouloir à
aucun prix de cette victoire de la
droite et nous sommes ici ce soir pour
envoyer ce message clair nous sommes ici
tous ensemble pour envoyer ce message
clair oui nous voulons garder ce
département à gauche claude bartolone
une figure du département a fait le
déplacement
le président de l'assemblée nationale
veut mobiliser les électeurs
nous quand il ya une élection vote quand
il y a la possibilité de voter on vote
parce que la république et la démocratie
ça s'entretient on se déplace on prend
cinq minutes on va mettre un bulletin de
vote dans ce département françois
hollande a fait son meilleur score à la
présidentielle
alors si le basculement avait lieu ce
serait une prise de guerre pour la
droite
alors je vous interroger dans de petites
secondes vous présente tu me verras
c'est notre partenaire du figaro tant
que interrogera d'or dans quelques
secondes
tout d'abord on va revenir un peu sur
cette union de la gauche françois
hollande on arrivait finalement et
départementale l'ont fait non vous savez
ici c'est pas comme ça que ça se
présente l'enjeu mais l'enjeu il est
simple
il est simple pour ce deuxième tour plus
rien' et il ne fait pas évacuer les
débats qui traversent la gauche c'est
effectivement ne pas faire basculer le
département à gauche vous en seine saint
denis a pas que ceux ci il ya des villes
qui ont basculé qui ont basculé à droite
aux dernières municipales qu'est-ce qui
se passe les politiques culturelles
elles sont mises à bas les politiques
d'engagement de programmes de logements
sociaux elles sont arrêtées dans ces
villes au blanc-mesnil à bobigny à
bobigny on a même des pratiques
politiques qui sont pas très loin du
clientélisme voire de pratiques
mafieuses
donc on a un peu partout une droite qui
met en danger la vie des populations et
dans un département populaire dans un
département où il ya autant besoin de
solidarité autant besoin de souffrances
sociales moi effectivement j'invite les
électeurs à se mobiliser et je leur dis
vous pourrez compter sur les communistes
pour garder ce département et ses
politiques sociales à gauche
mais au delà pour ce pour vous pour se
battre avec vous par exemple la rivière
il y avait des enseignants et ils disent
il faut que l'âge de moyens dans la
salle des maisons 1000 x ray vous
appeler à l'union pour ce deuxième tour
mais inquiète comment voulez que je
fasse autre aux mollahs mais après
comment est-ce qui vous ici je vous y
faire barrage à la droite bien sûr faut
bien michel va avoir des effets
notamment sur le long terme que cette
union vous appelez de vos voeux sur le
long terme sur le long terme joly dit il
faut le débat qui existe au plan
national et ça sera ça pour moi tirer
les leçons de ce qui s'est passé dans
cette élection qui s'était déjà passé
aux municipales et aux européennes c'est
qu'il faut changer de politique
gouvernementale
nous ne pouvons pas continuer par
exemple a privé la seine-saint-denis de
dotation collectivités locales nous ne
pouvons pas ne pas faire de plan de
rattrapage pour l'éducation en seine
saint denis pour la santé en seine saint
denis et les équipements hospitaliers et
c'est pas la droite qui va faire ça
parce que la droite elle elle propose
d'aller encore plus loin dans les coupes
dans les dépenses publiques et alors
donc c'est de ça dont on a besoin cette
année je reviens une petite seconde à y
avoir embobiné le film premier tour vous
partez avec les verts ou avec
les communistes quelques de temps en
temps avec la partie sociale il paraît
que jean christophe cambadélis est lui
qui le dit vous a fait des proposition
mirifique
avant ce premier tour et que vous avez
refusé qu en est-il mais écoutez ce
n'est pas donc dans toutes les élections
cantonales depuis toujours nous avons
présenté des candidats au premier tour
et quand il y avait 60 bien démarré en
banque
lorsqu'on y avait 61 départements à
gauche nous présentions des candidats au
premier tour mais ça donne vous gagnez à
l'université de présentation de
candidats au premier tour n'est pas
l'obstacle qu'est ce qui pose problème
qu'est ce qui pose problème aujourd'hui
dans le pays c'est que énormément
d'électeurs qui ne se reconnaissent pas
d'électeurs de gauche qui ont voulu la
victoire en 2012 et qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans la politique
gouvernementale et bien s'abstiennent ne
vont pas aux urnes ne comprennent pas
pourquoi on n'entend pas les messages
qu'ils n'arrêtent pas d'envoyer alors on
peut faire la politique de l'autruche et
puis pensez que ce problème n'existe pas
mais il continuera d'exister message
essentiel mais ça ne m'empêche pas moi
entre les deux tours de dire même si
nous allons continuer à nous battre pour
changer cette situation
il y à une urgence d'ici dimanche en
tout cas ne pas de prime abord parce qu
après alors et à présent on va
accueillir quand même notre partenaire
du figaro pour un décryptage de cette
actualité politique c'est la loupe du
scan
gym jarrassé bon jour vous nous parlez
d'un homme papa l'avant jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon et on l'a
pas trop entendu ces derniers jours il a
écrit sur son blog lire un passage qui a
retenu notre attention je vous lis
jamais les valeurs d'extrême droite
n'ont été aussi influente une partie des
gouvernementaux et elle même travaillé
par un corpus d'idées étrangère à notre
monde philosophiques comme lorsque valls
dénigre les roms ou macron propose aux
jeunes comme rêve de devenir
milliardaire la vague brune n'est pas
seulement politique
elle peut être d'abord un fait d'une
culture devenue dominante est ce que
vous êtes d'accord pierre le rang avec
cette analyse de l'idée qu'ils ont une
espèce de droitisation rampante de la
société que le gouvernement ferait
partie de la société non je ne le crois
pas des forces politiques wii actuelle
les forces politiques de droite
d'abord parce que ceux qui ont ouvert
les vannes pour le front national c'est
sarkozy c'est lui qui a banalisé le
premier l'idéologie du front national en
reprenant ses thèmes ont les popularise
en les justifiant
et c'est donc ils portent une
responsabilité et il a continué à le
faire d'ailleurs à la veille
à la veille du premier tour des
élections des margats mentale
responsable filet
le gouvernement va laisser et ses mots
très forts qu'eux aussi non mais moi je
n'en veux qu'à l'ère de jean luc
mélenchon vous me posez une question sur
ce que je pense moi moyens dit que
effectivement du côté du gouvernement à
faire le contraire de ce qui était
attendu par les forces populaires de ce
pays quand on avait dit on va s'attaquer
à la question européenne et qu'on ne le
fait pas et qu'on continue de courir
derrière angela merkel quand on dit on
va investir on va s'attaquer au pouvoir
de la finance
et qu'on ne le fait pas eh bien on
provoque une déception terrible chez les
gens qui sont le plus dans l'urgence et
effectivement on favorise de cette
manière là là la progression du front
national et de sa démagogie il ya un
autre problème quand même c'est qu'il
faut aussi et moi j'ai fait j'ai un peu
tapé du poing sur la table sur la
banalisation du front national c'est
qu'il faut un démonter la duperie du
front national qui fait les grands
discours qu'un grand vocabulaire
social et puis en vérité quand on
regarde concrètement ce qu'il commence à
faire là où ils prennent des
responsabilités ces systèmes ans
systématiquement ça tapait s'attaquer
aux classes populaires qu'il prétend
défendre en nous posant les vraies entre
eux évidemment sortant les enfants de
chômeurs des cantines etc etc alors
reparlons encore un peu de jean luc
mélenchon je suis si vous le voulez bien
je pars diable parce qu'il a fait il a
fait un choix qui de ne pas mener
campagne
chose qui voudrait que le parti de
gauche justement ça c'est la campagne il
a refusé la stratégie de rassemblement
que vous avez validé avec le parti
socialiste
eric coquerel hier en parler le bras
droit de jean luc mélenchon il disait le
traditionnel désistement républicain n'a
guère de sens quand des candidats de
gauche soutiennent un gouvernement qui
fait une politique de droite
que lui répondez-vous mais oui bien sûr
c'est sur cette question du deuxième
tour nous nous avons un désaccord en
divergence dernier nous avons nous avons
un désaccord sur cette question du
deuxième c'est pas le premier mais moi
je pense je pense que quand quand nous
sommes devant le danger devant lequel
nous nous trouvons c'est à dire des
beaucoup département qui peuvent passer
à droite voire des départements qui
peuvent être gagnés par le front
national
et bien moi je dis on ne mégote pas sur
le fait de faire barrage à ça donc
effectivement là tu nous n'avons pas les
mêmes
alors vous dites qu'on parle que de jean
luc mélenchon non mais un autre homme
aussi qui fait parler de lui
oui c'est mathieu gallet le pdg de radio
france il est un peu dans la tourmente
cette semaine après des révélations sur
son train de vie qui interviennent au
plus plus mauvais moment puisque il est
aussi fragilisé par une grève à radio
france a contre un plan de
restructuration des rédactions fleur
pellerin à la convoquer sèchement en lui
demandant produire un projet précis pour
l'entreprise est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est la bonne méthode pour mettre fin à
la grogne des salariés problème pour moi
n'est pas le train de vie de mathieu
gallet et fleur pellerin ne peuvent pas
ne peux pas non plus ne peut pas se
dédouaner de ses responsabilités
l'état vient de décider de réduire la
subvention à l'audiovisuel public france
télévisions et radio france et ensuite
en pèlerin fait comme si elle était pour
rien dans la situation indien mathieu
gallet débrouillez-vous et et et on
laisse ce saut
s'opposer les salariés et la direction
de l'entreprise
alors qu'en vérité il ya un problème
c'est que nous devons donner les moyens
à l'audiovisuel public de se développer
et de se rénover il ya sûrement des
choses à changer à radio france ça c'est
sûr et les syndicats les salariés le 10
mai la première des questions à poser
c'est est-ce que l'état prend ses
responsabilités l'état
le premier de responsables selon vous
c'est l'état et la baisse des dotations
mais bien sûr radio france déséquilibre
le budget le budget de radio france et
puis ensuite on dit mais qu'est ce que
vous faites vous nous présentez pas un
budget un budget digne de ce nom
oui et nous nous avons d'ailleurs
dénoncé c'est ce recul des subventions
de l'état à l'audiovisuel établi avec
l'état ne devait plus mais tout ça
françois hollande l'avait promis non
mais l'état a une responsabilité si nous
avons des audiovisuel public france
télévisions et radio france c'est parce
que nous pensons qu'il ya une mission de
service public qui doit être remplie
donc l'état a son mot à dire là dessus
et d'abord à donner les moyens après si
elle donne les moyens aux services
publics de vive qu'elle qu'elle donne
aussi son avis en lien avec les citoyens
avec les usagers avec les
représentations parlementaire sur ce que
devrait une politique de service public
digne de ce nom
oui il faut s'occuper de ça aussi mais
en l'occurrence le premier des problèmes
que rencontrent radio france est un
problème de déséquilibre budgétaire liés
aux choix qu'ils ont réparé par le
gouvernement alors on va passer à mardi
pierre laurent manuel valls annoncé
suspendre sa campagne pour 24 heures
après la catastrophe aérienne majeure
dans les alpes et puis la politique a
repris son cours avec des échanges à
distance entre manuel valls et nicolas
sarkozy
il était à quelques mètres d'écart le
premier ministre et le président de
l'ump se sont rendus chacun à leur
réunion de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale l'occasion pour manuel valls
d'enfoncer le clou en critiquant une
nouvelle fois la stratégie du ni-ni
choisi par nicolas sarkozy jean baptiste
daoulas à l'assemblée les ténors du ps
dénonce tankers la décision de nicolas
sarkozy de ne pas choisir entre le fn et
le parti socialiste
la faute morale c'est celle de monsieur
sarkozy qui avec un pur cynisme essaye
d'un côté de profiter d' attirer des
électeurs du front national sur ses
candidats et de l'autre côté se
satisfait du repos républicain on voit
bien que la seule idée qui est la sienne
c'est pas de proposer une alternative
aux français c'est de prendre sa
revanche au mans de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
puis c'est au tour de manuel valls de
faire la leçon à nicolas sarkozy je
trouve nicolas sarkozy très nerveux est
au fond très caricatural ses prises de
position aujourd'hui ne servent pas
l'intérêt général et ne servent pas la
république dont moi je lui demande de se
reprendre tranquillement sans être
nerveux je lui demande de réfléchir aux
conséquences de sa prise de position
c'est une faute en effet moral par
rapport aux valeurs de la république
c'est une faute politique qui ne sert
pas à la droite républicaine qui se
trouve du coup très divisée la campagne
du deuxième tour des départementales
devient un duel à distance entre nicolas
sarkozy et manuel valls
le président de l'ump et était également
en réunion de groupe à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui mais il ne s'est pas exprimé
à la sortie c'est christian jacob qui
est chargé de répondre au premier
ministre je voudrais tout d'abord dire à
manuel valls qu'il cesse d'hystériser la
campagne comme il l'a fait chaque jour
où il est sorti
chacune de ses interventions le ps
effondrés et les extrêmes monter
donc je serais lui je rentrerai chez moi
et je mens fermerait à double tour ce
sera mieux pour l'intérêt général
mais le crash de l'avion de la compagnie
germanwings a mis entre parenthèses la
polémique
manuel valls a décidé de suspendre sa
campagne pendant 24 heures est ce que
pour vous pierre laurent daniel valls a
raison de se poser en rempart suprême
façon front national moi je pense que là
la nécessité de se mobiliser contre le
front national est indispensable et je
n'ai pas attendu manuel valls pour le
faire en ce qui me concerne mais je
pense qu'il faut être conséquent
il y a dénoncé des propos et des
propositions du front national qui sont
à mon avis extrêmement dangereuse pour
la démocratie est qui et qui souvent
trompent les gens parce qu'elles sont
masquées derrière un discours pseudo
sociale il faut s'expliquer sur sa avec
les électeurs mais à agde après ça il
faut aussi mener une politique qui
résorbe les inégalée finma chômage ont
été invités hier ils sont à nouveau en
augmentation en marquant deux points
donc si on n'arrive pas à faire reculer
le chômage si on prend pas des mesures
pour ça et bien effectivement le risque
que le front national continue de
prospérer sur cette misère sociale
existe donc moi je pense que si on veut
avoir un discours anti front national
conséquent il faut en tirer les
conséquences en changeant de cap
politique en mettant de l'argent sans
les urgences sociales en mettant de
l'argent dans le développement de
l'emploi je vous propose une déclaration
c'est celle de martine aubry indique
qu'il ya une vraie violence contre la
politique actuelle les mots très forts
le mot violence vous le reprenez aussi à
votre compte et bien sûr il suffit
d'aller discuter sur le terrain pour
s'en apercevoir
moi j'ai entamé depuis le début janvier
un tour de france et j'ai décidé d'aller
à chaque fois sur le terrain et je vais
le faire pendant six mois parce que je
veux retrouver le sens du dialogue
politique direct avec les citoyens
partout où je vais il ya une très grande
colère contre la situation et contre les
inégalités qui continue de se développer
qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'en quand
les gens voient que le pdg de sanofi
continue de toucher des millions et des
millions
on euros par mois alors que cette
entreprise soit dit entre nos
entreprises du médicament vie des
remboursements de la sécurité sociale
indirectement parce que c'est quand même
comme ça que ça marche et que les gens
dans l'entreprise continue d'être
licenciés contre d'ailleurs en
contournant même la législation sociale
qui existe parce que le plan social à
sanofi a été annulée par exemple 11
septembre mais les licenciements ont
quand même lieu
voilà tout ça évidemment ça provoque
scène en colère et dont on le compare à
laquelle il faut s'attaquer
vous parliez déchets du chômage on va
s'y intéresser toutes les deux ce
mercredi mais mauvaise nouvelle le
chômage repart à la hausse +0 4% soit
12000 800 demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires manuel valls a réagi à
cette annonce on va l'écouter sur les
deux premiers mois de l'année nous avons
une baisse du chômage baisse forte au
mois de janvier aux malheureusement au
cours de ce mois de février
mais nous savons parfaitement et nous
savions que tant que nous n'avons pas
une croissance plus forte autour de 1,5
pour cent
il est difficile de créer l'emploi je
sais que pour beaucoup de français
ils sont au chômage ils sont en
difficulté ces chiffres et ces
statistiques ne veulent pas dire grand
chose mais l'année 2015 c'est l'année du
retour de la croissance et de la
confiance et ça j'en suis convaincu
convaincu par manuel valls ou pas non
pas du tout d'abord bon arrêtons avec
les chiffres
ça augmente et un mois ça a baissé l'eau
tout ça le chômage il a augmenté de 6 et
demi pour cent sur la dernière année
donc la tendance elle est
malheureusement très fortement c'est le
résultat de la politique l'avait dit
depuis le début de la mission ait été
effectivement manuel valls dit tant que
la croissance ne sera pas là mais si par
exemple on continue on confirme
mais moi je pense qu'on devrait revenir
dessus qu'on confirme qu'on va supprimer
20 ou 30 milliards d'euros ou
collectivités locales c'est très concret
c'est des budgets d'investissements
publics qu'on ne fera pas quand on n'est
pas l'argent qu'on devrait mettre sur la
rénovation
de l'habitat pour lutter contre la
précarité énergétique quand on met pas
l'argent sur la construction du logement
est bien effectivement on n'a pas les
emplois nécessaires si on mettait en
adéquation la réponse aux besoins des
français et bien on est la création
d'emplois on verra on venait que l'on
peut retrouver quelque chose de vertu
mais pour ça il faut enlever les
manettes mais s'il arrivait sur
l'échangé c'est la croissance des
dividendes de manuel valls n'entend pas
changer de politique ni france en
magasin d'accord ils osent mise mais
c'est pourtant inévitable si on veut
écouter un peu ce que dit le pays
c'est inévitable parce que cette
politique pour le moment elle ne réussit
pas politiquement elle ne réussit pas
socialement elle ne réussit pas les
économiquement je veux bien qu'on nous
dise encore une fois grands moyens les
incroyants possible encore mais je les
travaille avant tout cas moi je moi je
mais moi je suis pas un connard
médiateur dans la vie politique qui
regarde tout ça moi je suis un acteur de
la vie politique elles sont les gens
travaillent là j
cette noria sont les insurgés alors là
il est d'abord il faut mettre sur la
table il faut il faut rendre majoritaire
le soutien majoritaire a des idées que
nous défendons il faut s'attaquer aux
dividendes ils sont arrêtés de mettre
fin aux démences à la française mais il
y aura pas vous savez moi je connais
très bien toutes les expériences
européennes vous l'avais dit je suis
président du parti de travailler avec
syrie n'avait rien qu'avec la mouche et
l'espagne avec podemos avec toutes ses
forces
eh bien elles convergent avec nous sur
une idée simple c'est mettre fin aux
politiques d'austérité parce qu'elles
dépriment la croissance elle développe
le chômage est au contraire remettre là
les ressources disponibles dans la
relance sociale et ses ressources
existent la banque centrale on nous dit
a pas d'argent la banque centrale
européenne vient d'annoncer début
janvier qu'elle allait remettre 1140
milliards dans la machine bancaires et
financières européennes
à quoi va servir cet argent qu'est-ce
que bnp paribas la société générale et
les banques françaises vont faire de cet
argent qu'il aurait distribué à
quasiment zéro pour cent ou 0 5% par la
banque centrale
d'être aussi difficile d'obtenir du
crédit des banques françaises pour
soutenir l'emploi et la création
d'emplois alors qu'elles ont cet argent
la dernière question très courte
il se murmure qu'il pourrait y avoir un
remaniement après les élections
vous en ferez partie à la question
sectorisation de politique je viens de
vous le dire nous tous il n'y a pas de
changement politique banon je vais pas
au gouvernement pour continuer à faire
une politique il ya une inflexion sai
salée pour laquelle c'est ce qu'on
appelle une inflexion s'il nbc si on
change quasiment rien ben non qu'est-ce
que si on change carrément de cap
eh bien nous on nous on est prêts on est
prêts à la discussion si on nous dit on
va par exemple suspendre les pressions
dotation collectivités locales parce
qu'on veut soutenir l'investissement
public
si on nous dit la loi qu'on n'a pas fait
pour interdire les licenciements
boursiers
finalement on va la mettre à l'ordre du
jour du parlement
si on nous dit plusieurs choses comme ça
nous on est prêts à discuter mais déjà
chez un chef
oui chiche mais malheureusement j'ai lu
comme vous les déclarations de manuel
valls et de françois hollande j'entends
pas qu'on se dirige vers ça donc nous
allons continuer nous à rassembler les
forces qui pensent comme nous que ce
changement de cap est nécessaire pour
pour le verre et un père gagner le plus
vieil maintenant on va retourner sur le
terrain faisant le vrai dans l'un des
départements les plus convoités qui
pourraient basculer
on va s'arrêter sur le département de
l'aisne département qui pourrait
basculer vers le front national dès
dimanche prochain c'est un reportage de
cécile 6 je vous rappelle quelque chose
donc parfait avec ses 42 % au premier
tour le candidat fn du canton de
soissons 1 emmanuel chassaigne ou est
arrivé en tête nationale pour lui s'il a
réussi à rassembler autant au premier
tour c'est qu'il a fait une campagne
proche des gens contrairement à ses
adversaires
voilà le ps lui-même le modem les verts
le front de gauche vous propose de
lutter contre le front national
deuxièmement de lutter contre le front
national troisièmement de lutter contre
le front national voilà leur programme
ne faire que par et la route au front
national on ne prend lui parle que de ça
on ne s'occupe pas des électeurs de nos
villes de nos campagnes qui sont
complètement en désarroi total sur son
canton beaucoup d'habitants sont déçus
de la politique
vous savez que c'est quoi que joe et moi
le front national voilà le front
national que joueur et j'ai pas peur de
le dire je suis en face j'en ai ras le
bol à 1,50 en outre mettre en question
sénat michel à soissons - le fn sera
face à un binôme de droite car la liste
de gauche arrivée en troisième position
s'est désisté ce que nous avons fait
avec nos partenaires europe ecologie les
verts le parti communiste français avec
le parti radical de gauche également
c'est évidemment de retirer les
candidatures qui pouvait se maintenir en
triangulaire pour éviter autant que
faire se peut que le front national ne
parvienne à conquérir encore de nombreux
cantons pour l'ump en revanche a choisi
de maintenir ses candidats dans le
département avec finalement le même
argument que les socialistes être une
digue face au fn le fond de l'histoire
réfléchissez bien c'est quoi c'est de
laisser un certain nombre d'électeurs de
l'ump sans solution deuxième tôt
peut-être en prenant un bulletin de vote
que pourtant je leur défendent prendre
mais qui par exaspération vis du
gouvernement vis-à-vis du gouvernement
prendrait un bulletin qui ferait battre
la gauche parce que c'est de ça
aujourd'hui dont on a envie d électeurs
à guise et à essômes-sur-marne deux
équipes ump ont toutefois choisi de ne
pas suivre les directives du parti
elles se sont retirées des triangulaires
où elle était arrivée en troisième
position derrière le fn et le ps
alors nous avait dit en début d'émission
que vous vouliez pas faire de pronostic
cependant est ce que vous estimez que le
front national peut gagner un
département des vosges soit oui en
danger c'est pour ça qu'il faut se
mobiliser contre ce danger et tout faire
pour l'empêcher
parce que les conséquences pour les
populations de laine par exemple que je
connais très bien qu'ils sont des
populations très en difficulté seront
catastrophiques contre le front national
juste un maudit on attendait le rsa
c'est ça le problème et on va appliquer
sur le rsa et on va donner aux personnes
âgées
c'est un mensonge ce que fera le front
national s'est piquée de l'argent à ceux
qui ont le rsa je rappelle que ces 533
euros par mois
c'est à dire des gens qui vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté et il y
aura pas un euro de plus vous m'entendez
pas un euro de plus pour les personnes
âgées
donc en vérité ce mensonge là il faut le
dénoncer parce que je comprends la
colère de tout un tas de lecteurs face à
la situation sociale qui l'aurait fait
mais je le redis la voie vers le front
national est une impasse qui risque de
s'avérer extrêmement douloureuse
justement parce qu'ils sont les plus en
souffrance dans ce département donc il
faut empêcher ça et là on a bien compris
il vous reste quelques heures encore
pour faire campagne la campagne va
bientôt se clore on va passer au plus de
l'hebdo simon barbarie ne rejoint
bonjour simon allard aux fermes la tâche
des bardes départementale vont nous
parler d'un nouveau magazine qui vient
de sortir et à moi so sexy voilà oui
pierre laurent bonjour vous avez un
ancien journaliste vous avez été
directeur de la rédaction de l'humanité
donc ce nouveau titre dans la presse
papier ne vous a pas échappé le magazine
society un magazine destiné à
dépoussiérer les hebdos d'information
deux titres sont déjà sorti un premier
numéro avec l'interview de françois
fillon
deuxième numéro plus surprenant françois
hollande lui-même se prête à l'exercice
vous avez noté l'iconographie très
tendance très décalé ça nous rappelle un
petit peu les années 60 et est intitulé
la grande confession s'est tenue une
grande confessions d'une dizaine de
pages quand même mais pourtant ce sont
les photons qu'on retient des photos
très cocasse très inhabituelle des
photos qui déconstruisent cette stature
de chef d'état un président qui fait
mode est un sympathique proche des gens
et pourtant son que ces photos sont en
contradiction totale avec les propres
mots de françois hollande
puisque il déplore dans cette interview
le besoin d'anecdotes d'insolites et
d'inédit dans la vie politique française
il parle aussi de la gravité de sa
fonction le président et le chef de la
famille française la mort habite la
fonction présidentielle référence
notamment aux attentes à 2 janvier
dernier alors pierre laurent ma question
c'est est-ce qu'un magazine comme
society avec une interview politique
comme ça c'est un illustre pas le
dilemme propre politique tiraillé entre
fond et forme de leurs messages entre
l'image et le discours écoutez j'ai vous
avez dit ça m'a pas échappé si ça me
laisse échapper une j'ai vu la gêne ou
là sans refaire un brave rénale
j'ai vu la sortie du journal mais je ne
l'est pour tout vous dire j'ai je me
suis pas besoin d'engranger pas
mais non je crois que moi il n'y a pas
de on accorde de mon point de vue je
sais qu'on accorde beaucoup la forme
c'est toujours du fond aussi un donc
c'est ça compte mais il ya un il ya une
survalorisation de mon point de vue de
la com de ce que j'appelle la com par
rapport à la sincérité du message les
gens ne sont pas des imbéciles et donc
on peut toujours croire qu'on va les
attraper avec des messages pseudo
publicitaires mais en fait les gens sont
sont beaucoup plus sensé que ça derrière
ces messages là qu'ils écoutent parfois
avec beaucoup de plaisir ou pas ou avec
beaucoup d'énervement et bien il regarde
où est leur intérêt ou pas ils savent
très bien décrypter les messages et vers
ces gens c'est ici aussi aussi à gogo
compenser ils réfléchissent beaucoup moi
dès que je vais sur le terrain je
m'aperçois que les gens au fond
réfléchissent beaucoup au message qu'on
leur envoie et parfois il y en a qui
peuvent se faire attraper par delà comme
mais ça suffit vraiment pas à les
convaincre justement ce que disait c'est
mon tout cas c'est que les enquêtes de
gravité vous estimez qu'il est toujours
en recherche de postures françois
hollande de stature de posture écoutez
je je je je je n'en sais rien je moi ce
qui m'intéresse et il est président de
la république c'est de savoir si le
message qu'ils portent et un message à
la hauteur des ambitions que d'un pays
comme la france et pour le moment je
dans certaines circonstances comme les
attentats oui mais dans beaucoup
d'autres n'ont donc moi je porte une
critique sur le fond de son message de
son de son discours et c'est sur ça que
j'espère qu'il y aura un débat ça
n'empêche pas qu'il faille renouveler et
moi je me pose souvent la question pour
le parti communiste aussi notre la forme
de notre message
jeudi jour de magazines et de toute
façon mais moi coup vache à lait moi je
suis un laborieux je suis curieux dans
fortis fait de 9 et nous aussi on
travaillait souvent des messages de ce
type mais mais je sais que ça ne suffit
pas voilà c'est ça merci pierre laurent
verra bien le résultat en tout cas d
élection de départ soit à monter à 20
heures dimanche sur lozon merci d'avoir
été notre invité et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine même lieu même heure
palais
moi